Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a comedy film called
“The Bandit Hound”. Watch out and take care!
Bandit is an Australian Shepherd
trained to be a thief by his masters,
Manny and Willy. In the opening scene, he
walks into a bank with a bag and a note
attached to it. The guard doesn’t care to
check the little dog and lets it through.
The cashier reads the note that says
the dog is attached to an explosive
which will go off if they do not fill
his backpack with hundred dollar bills.
She quickly does as told, after which Bandit
runs away. Outside, his masters are waiting for
him in a car. They check his bag and throw out a
tracking device used as a trap. It turns out that
the explosive was fake, used as a way to scare the
cashier. While Manny praises Bandit for his work,
Willy isn’t fond of the dog. They drive back to
a warehouse and start counting the money.
Outside, a policeman arrives looking for the
robbers. He holds them at gunpoint but Bandit
saves his masters by attacking the policeman.
Manny and Willy manage to escape while the dog
is captured. Somewhere else, a fifteen-year-old
boy named Owen is riding his bicycle down the
neighborhood. He is suddenly stopped by a group of
bullies. They push him around and call him names
even though Owen tries to befriend them. A girl
from a neighboring house feels bad for him and
lets her dog out to chase the bullies away. Owen
thanks the girl and returns home to his mother,
Joanne. Owen’s father died a year ago because
of an illness. Ever since, the family has been
facing financial problems. They have moved
to the town in hopes of new opportunities
and to be closer to their only relative,
Auntie Deb. Now that they have settled in,
Owen wants to get a pet dog. Joanne is
skeptical, but she cannot say no to her son.
In the meantime, Manny and Willy are tense because
they can no longer make money. Manny wants to get
Bandit back but Willy insists he train a new dog.
He even steals a dog but Manny refuses to train
anyone other than Bandit. He gets on his laptop
and searches all the dog shelters in the town.
Only a few minutes in, he sees that Bandit is
being held in the Heart Rescue dog Adoption
center. Owen and his mother get to the shelter
before them. Auntie Deb thinks bringing a dog home
is a bad idea but Joanne insists on fulfilling her
son’s wishes. The owner of the adoption center,
Trevor, is a friendly man who seems to be
interested in Joanne. He introduces Owen
to Bandit and the two instantly get alone. A
while later, the family brings Bandit home.
After they leave, Manny arrives at the
shelter and asks to meet Bandit.
When he discovers that he has already been
adopted, he goes through the adoption forms and
finds out Owen’s address. He plans to get his dog
back one way or the other. At Owen’s house, Joanne
and Deb discuss the family’s financial issues. Deb
wants Joanne to borrow money from her but Joanne
wants to do everything on her own. Bandit hears
the word “money” and is instantly alerted. Yet,
he refuses to come out from under the bed.
Owen tries to bribe him with toys and treats
but the dog still doesn’t move. He thinks that
Bandit doesn’t like him but his mother asks him
to have some patience. After the family goes
to sleep, Bandit finally comes out from under
the bed and runs outside. At the same time,
Manny and Willy arrive there looking for him.
Manny sneaks inside the house through the pet door
while Bandit runs away to a nearby restaurant. The
guests think he is cute and let him play around.
But when they are busy, Bandit steals money from
a woman’s purse and returns home. On his way,
he also steals from a homeless person. Back at
the house the robbers drive away after looking
for Bandit everywhere but not finding him.
The following day, Owen takes the dog to a vet to
make sure he doesn’t have any illness. The doctor
checks him and confirms that Bandit is healthier
than ever. Everything goes well until after they
leave and the doctor notices his wallet is
missing. That afternoon, Owen is playing with his
toys in the backyard when the girl who saved him
from the bullies approaches him. She introduces
herself as Lily and asks to be his friend. The
two chat for a while before she leaves. Later,
Owen and Bandit are returning from the grocery
store when the bullies stop them again. They
make fun of Owen and snatch his bag of groceries.
Bandit sees a twenty-dollar bill inside their bag
and steals it without anyone noticing. When
the bullies threaten to throw stones at them,
Owen takes a stand for himself and hits them with
tomatoes. Back at home, Joanne is crying because
she had a miscommunication at her work and got
fired on her first day. Auntie Deb and her husband
try to console her when Owen arrives at the house.
Although Joanne pretends like everything is going
great in front of him, Owen understands that
his mother is having financial difficulties.
Suddenly, Bandit hands him the twenty dollar
bill he had stolen from the bullies. Before he
can figure out where the money came from, someone
rings their doorbell. It is one of the bullies and
his mother complaining about someone stealing his
lunch money. They also accuse Owen of hitting the
kids. The woman threatens to call animal control
and leaves. Owen realizes that his dog was the one
who stole the money. The following day, they go to
the park to train. Owen firmly believes that what
Bandit did was wrong and wants him to learn to
choose dog treats instead of money. While he is at
it, Lily comes to talk to him, along with her dog
Lucy. The two decide to go on a date to see the
Christmas decorations around town. After spending
the entire day together and having a lot of fun,
they hug and return home. The following day,
Joanne goes to the dog shelter to meet Trevor.
She initially wants to talk about Bandit’s
relationship with her son but the direction
of the conversation changes when Trevor mentions
he wants to date her. Joanne is unsure because she
has never been with anyone other than her husband
but she agrees to go out on a date anyway.
Somewhere else, Owen is training Bandit in a park.
Bandit notices a van and follows it to the bank.
Two policemen are loading the van with money
from the state’s treasury. The dog hides under
the vehicle and steals a bag of money when
no one is looking. While he is running away,
one of the policemen named Albert sees him but
doesn’t think much of it. Soon, they realize
a bag is missing and start searching for it.
Meanwhile, Owen finds Bandit under a bush with
bundles of money. Although the kid knows
that talking the money would be a crime,
he does so anyway to help his mother. On his way
back home, he meets auntie Deb who hands him an
envelope with a check for a thousand dollars.
She asks him to hand it to Joanne as an early
Christmas present from her side. Back in the
bank, detective Decker is assigned to find out
where the money went. Albert claims that it might
have been stolen by a dog. While everyone laughs,
the detective believes him since he also worked
on the last robbery that Bandit was a part of.
On reaching home, Owen tears the check and keeps
a couple thousand dollars in the envelope instead.
Joanne thinks that her sister is trying to
help her like always and keeps the money.
The following day, Owen decides to return
the money without being caught. But after
seeing the news about the stolen money on
TV, he gets scared and changes his mind.
When his mother asks him what is wrong, he
makes an excuse saying that he has to go out
on a date with Lily. After the interaction,
he goes to Lily’s house and asks her out.
Somewhere else, the robbers also see the news
and figure out that Bandit has stolen the money.
They decide to get it from Owen before he is
caught. That way, the blame will fall on the
kid and they will have the money. Owen and Lily
go to a candy store where he buys her a lollipop.
The other kids surround him, asking him to buy one
for them as well. To impress Lily, he agrees to
buy them everything they want. The girls who used
to ignore him before, start to flirt with him,
much to Lily’s annoyance. He brings the entire
group to a toy shop and buys them everything they
pick. Lily asks him if he can afford it to which
he smugly replies that it is his money. Lily is
unsettled by his new personality but doesn’t say
anything. Outside the toy store, a couple stops
to play with Bandit but he steals the woman’s
necklace and runs away. At the same time, Albert
recognises him and starts chasing the dog.
Eventually, the couple and all the kids
follow behind. Bandit manages to fool them and
gets away after hiding inside a photo booth. Back
home, Joanne and Trevor return from a date and are
about to kiss but are interrupted by Bandit. Soon,
the truth comes out and the family is brought
to the police station along with the dog.
A policeman interrogates them and asks them if
they have the money. While the others deny it,
Owen realizes his mistake and hands the bag of
money to the officer. He decides to let the family
go since they had no part in the robbery. However,
he has to hand Bandit to animal control where he
will soon be put down. Owen and Bandit share an
emotional goodbye before separating. He returns
home sad that his best friend is about to be
killed. Trevor tries to cheer him up claiming that
he can choose any dog from the shelter. However,
Owen knows that no one can replace Bandit.
At night, Joanne comes to his room to check on
him and finds him asleep. But, Owen had only been
pretending. He has decided to go to animal control
headquarters to release his dog. He packs up his
bags with clothes and other necessities, planning
to move to a different state with Bandit.
As Owen is about to leave, Lily stops him outside
the house. Owen thinks that she is about to tell
everyone but in contrast, she wishes him luck and
kisses him on the cheek. Following that, he cycles
to the headquarters and swiftly releases Bandit
from his cage. But, what he doesn’t know is that
Manny and Willy are waiting for him outside, ready
to kidnap the dog. When Owen tries to scream,
they abduct him and bring him to a warehouse.
They had hoped to get the money that Bandit had
stolen from the bank and are disappointed after
finding out that Owen returned it. So instead,
Manny leaves Willy to look after Owen and goes to
rob a bank with Bandit. The next morning, Joanne
goes into Owen’s room to wake him up, only to find
him missing. In the meantime, Manny poses as blind
and enters a bank with Bandit. He uses a guard’s
gun to threaten the cashier and asks for money.
Bandit and the cashier go to the vault to fill
up the bag. When the dog returns with the money,
he and Manny drive away. Back in the warehouse,
Owen gets his hands on a gun and threatens Willy
to go to the police. Just then, Manny and
the dog arrive at the place. On seeing Willy
trying to attack Owen, Bandit jumps on him. They
struggle and the dog is shot in the process.
The policemen come to the warehouse at the
right time and get the dog to a vet. Meanwhile,
Manny and Willy drive away while being pursued by
a police car. They are happy that they at least
have the money but soon realize that Bandit fooled
them. Instead of the money, the bag is filled with
sticky notes. In the following scene, Owen is in
the hospital praying that the dog is alive. The
doctor comes outside the operating room and gives
him the good news. A few days later, the town’s
mayor honors Bandit and Owen for their bravery and
helping the police to capture the robbers. They
are given ten thousand dollars prize money each.
The entire town praises them for their bravery. In
the last scene, we see that Bandit and Lily's dog
have made several puppies together. Owen and Lily
sell the puppies to people in a yard sale.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification, and leave a like
to help the channel out. Thank You for watching.